take a look this is a live look right
now up there at Lee Canyon which is open
for the season today is opening day and
the chair lifts are running so did we
hit the go live button on the website
there let's do that I just want to make
sure because we can see people here we
go down in the bottom of the screen uh
people oh you got there there they are
they're all in line they're waiting for
the chair lift you got folks with their
skis and their snowboards it's been
snowing up on the mountain through the
morning hours and there it looks like
there is more to come now this is the
view looking to the north where we've
had some cells that opened up over U.S
95 here in the last half hour or so and
they've been traveling now over the uh
these are the Sheep mountains to the
north of the valley look how dark up
there more rain and snow spreading now
over the North End and the farther you
are in the North End of the valley you
could be getting in on some rain we'll
check the radar here coming up shortly
lots of 50's around the valley this
afternoon at noon most of the the valley
is sitting in the sunshine but the
closer you are to the mountains to the
west and the north you might be getting
in on some of that rain and definitely
snow up in the mountains 54 in Mesquite
52 at Indian Springs 51 in Pahrump 35 in
Caliente and yes up in the mountains
it's cold 30s right now for Kyle Canyon
and 20's up there at Lee Canyon 24 in
Ely 37 in Reno and we've got 63 in
Laughlin so the forecast for Mount
Charleston we're still looking at the
chance of snow for the next couple of
hours or more and then cloudy skies and
highs only in those mid 30s this is the
latest radar image right now where you
can see this cell that's opening up
right up there around Floyd Lamb Park
and the neighborhoods into the north
northwest part of the valley so still
some rain along U.S 95 up in the
Northwest Sky Canyon even maybe even
down to Centennial Hills getting in on
some of these showers here as these
cells are coming off the mountain and
forming in some rain showers now across
the northwest
so the most of the valley really not
looking for any chance of rain but the
Northwest Valley getting in on some of
that moisture that's spinning on the
back side of this low that moved through
the area last night it's over in Utah
but the back side of that low is
spitting moisture into Southern Nevada
today cold air continues across most of
the country with warm air across the
South showers stretched out from Texas
to the east coast and even up to the
Northeast so mostly sunny today upper
50's we'll still see the chance of those
showers up in the north northwest snow
in the mountains tonight will be clear
and cold and look for the full moon wow
it's going to be a beautiful cold
December full moon tonight mostly sunny
for the rest of the week but then
another system this weekend John brings
us a better chance of rain on Sunday for
the valley and snow in the mountains and
then cooler next week so we need the
rain desperately we need the rain and
man I want more snow in the mountains
let's bring it on